good morning i'm lieutenant david
valente with the las vegas metropolitan
police department homicide sex crimes
bureau here to brief you on a homicide
investigation that is currently ongoing
first i want to advise everyone with the
morning commute
uh to be cautious because we do have 215
the eastbound travel lanes from las
vegas boulevard down to approximately
warm springs are currently closed down
during the investigation we're working
diligently to get those reopened and
they should be open in less than an hour
from now
as far as the actual incident we're
investigating
we have a homicide where preliminary
information it looks like we had a road
rage incident some sort of altercation
occurring up on the 215 while traveling
eastbound
two cars
would be side by side
unknown argument started at which time
one of the vehicles fired rounds into
our victim vehicle
the victim driver was struck
causing him to crash his vehicle into
the center divider
before coming to a rest farther down the
road on 215.
there was a second female in the vehicle
that was also struck by gunfire
they have been
the deceased is approximately a 25 year
old black male
and the female is approximately 25 year
old black female she's been transported
to umc
believed to be in critical but stable
condition right now suffering from
gunshot wounds
suspects are not in custody right now
they're currently outstanding and we are
definitely looking for any public
assistance anyone at approximately 2 20
in the morning is when this call came in
so anyone would have been traveling
anywhere eastbound on the 215 possibly
even coming off of the i-15 on to the
215 we do not know where this initially
started before it turned into gunfire
but anyone seeing two vehicles
that might have been slowing down looked
like some sort of road rage incident or
seeing uh shots fired seeing the
accident
ultimately on 215 eastbound there past
the airport connector
absolutely request your assistance call
in to lvmpd
you can call crime stoppers to stay
anonymous you can even email uh homicide
at homicide at lbmpd.com
so with that are there any questions any
description for a vehicle
right now very vague description we have
a newer model we believe four-door
possibly gray sedan uh possibly occupied
up to four times that would be the
suspect that would be the suspect
vehicle
anything else
that's it thank you very much is the
driver who is deceased then the driver
of the victim vehicle is deceased on
scene yes
what part of the 215 east ground did
that vehicle come to a rest
uh several hundred yards east of the
airport connector and the warm springs
flyover
so it could have happened as stated
several hundred yards even a mile west
of that and who knows where the actual
altercation started
before going to that length so literally
anyone that saw anything involving a
couple vehicles chasing each other
driving side by side
cutting each other off anything like
that definitely give metro a call do you
have an update on where the closure
starts and how much longer it will stay
in place it starts it starts at las
vegas boulevard traveling eastbound on
215
to warm springs
they're getting close should be opening
up 30 45 minutes from now
thank you very much
[Music]
thank you sir
thanks a lot
do you know